[Musica]
il progresso tecnologico è inutile e
senza senso Se poi non viene reso
accessibile a tutti e quando dico tutti
intendo veramente tutti
senza nessuna distinzione
vi siete mai chiesti a che cosa serva la
tecnologia E perché debba progredire Beh
uno degli scopi principali della
tecnologia è quello di migliorare la
vita delle persone e lo fa attraverso
l'automatizzazione o la facilitazione di
alcuni compiti quotidiani
e quindi una vita migliore per tutti
passa anche attraverso un accesso
universale alla tecnologia
mi chiamo Raffaella panizzon sono una
linguista di formazione e dal 2018 mi
occupo di assistenti vocali
oggi vorrei parlarvi di come la
linguistica associata all'intelligenza
artificiale
o elaborazione del linguaggio naturale o
enelp dal suo acronimo inglese venga
utilizzata negli assistenti vocali
proprio per migliorare la vita delle
persone
potenziandone le capacità e rendendole
più autonome in caso di necessità
Ma che cos'è esattamente un assistente
vocale ma probabilmente molti di voi già
lo sanno magari alcuni di voi ne
possiedono uno Ma per chi non lo sapesse
un assistente vocale è in sostanza un
software che permette di eseguire dei
comandi impartiti attraverso la voce
per utilizzarlo dobbiamo prima dire una
parola di attivazione che può essere Ehi
Google Siri Alexa
e poi impartire un comando come ad
esempio Accendi la luce metti della
musica Che tempo farà domani e
l'assistente
eseguirà il comando al posto nostro
e oggi questa tecnologia la diamo così
per scontata ormai parliamo con la TV
con il frigorifero
la macchina del caffè Le automobili no
ma in realtà per decenni questa idea è
stata relegata esclusivamente
all'ambito della fantascienza
e originariamente questa idea Non nasce
come un'idea utilitaristica ma nasce da
un sogno
Il sogno di trasformare l'interazione
uomo macchina in un dialogo simile a
quello che abbiamo tre esseri umani e
cioè riuscire a dialogare con una
macchina
utilizzando lo strumento che ci viene
più naturale e cioè la voce
alcuni di voi si ricorderanno ad esempio
di Star Trek o di Supercar Ecco ad
esempio Star Trek dove ci sono questi
esploratori dello spazio che dialogano
in maniera del tutto naturale con il
computer di bordo è stata proprio
l'ispirazione per creare Alexa
se ora via un po' più chiaro
che cosa sia un assistente vocale forse
è un po' più misterioso riuscire ad
immaginare come questa tecnologia ci
comprenda e ci risponda
Ebbene lo fa attraverso la linguistica
la linguistica ci dà un modello teorico
di rappresentazione della lingua questo
modello viene poi preso da degli
algoritmi di Machine Learning per
comprendere il linguaggio naturale cioè
il linguaggio parlato dagli esseri umani
ora vi faccio vedere un esempio di come
funziona
immaginate di avere degli utenti di
qualsiasi tipo
utilizzano una parola di invocazione poi
dicono Accendi la luce
quindi inviano un input acustico ad un
dispositivo Da questo momento comincia
l'elaborazione
abbiamo un primo modulo che SR che si
occupa del riconoscimento automatico del
parlato e che esegue una trascrizione
del comando abbiamo poi nlu che invece
si occupa della comprensione del
linguaggio naturale e che esegue una
classificazione dell'input
alla fine può esserci un altro modulo
che si chiama TTS che è un Text to
Speech e che è sostanzialmente ciò che
l'assistente risponde all'utente e
infine il comando viene eseguito
Allora quello che fa sostanzialmente la
nel P è proprio questo Cioè trasformare
il linguaggio naturale il linguaggio
macchina
questa è la cosa straordinaria che oggi
riusciamo a fare combinando la
linguistica con l'intelligenza
artificiale gli assistenti vocali però
sono stati anche dei grandi alleati
durante il periodo di isolamento della
pandemia e proprio anche a seguito della
pandemia la platea di utenti di questa
tecnologia sia notevolmente ampliata per
darvi un senso molto concreto di quanto
sia diffusa questa tecnologia vi do un
paio di numeri nel 2021 si calcolava che
il mercato degli Smart speaker a livello
globale valesse Circa 7 miliardi di
dollari
Per quanto riguarda l'Italia invece
il mercato della Smart Home ha visto in
particolare per gli assistenti vocali
per gli Smart speaker una crescita del
25%, tra il 2020 e il 2021 quindi in
piena pandemia e gli italiani hanno
acquistato prima gli elettrodomestici e
poi subito dopo gli Smart speaker
Adesso vorrei fare un sondaggio qui tra
la platea
alzi la mano che ho mai usato un
assistente vocale
Insomma Dai siamo siamo in linea con le
statistiche vedo Vedo che molti di voi
hanno familiarità con questa tecnologia
ma un numero sempre maggiore di utenti
Però significa anche dover andare a
rispondere ad esigenze di fruizione
accessibilità sempre più varie e sempre
più complesse pensiamo ai bambini agli
anziani ma anche non vedenti non udenti
o persone che possono avere difficoltà
nel parlato
Che cos'è l'accessibilità
quando pensiamo alla parola
accessibilità pensiamo a qualcosa di
associato ad una disabilità permanente
Ecco io oggi vorrei cambiare il modo in
cui pensate l'accessibilità perché
l'accessibilità il problema
dell'accessibilità in realtà un problema
che ci riguarda tutti ma anche le
soluzioni che possiamo trovare a questo
problema possono portare beneficio a
tutti
vi racconto una cosa che mi è successa
12 anni fa ho cominciato a soffrire di
ulcere corneali quindi delle lacerazioni
spontanee della cornea Ho dovuto quindi
subire un intervento chirurgico agli
occhi e durante la convalescenza mi sono
ritrovata ad essere praticamente cieca
per una settimana
non ero in grado di svolgere le mansioni
più normali quindi non riuscivamo a
muovermi in casa a mangiare da sola a
lavarmi a medicarmi ero completamente
dipendente dall'aiuto dei miei genitori
Io ero sempre rimasta la stessa persona
di prima ma la mia capacità di svolgere
dei compiti era cambiata
e questo mi ha fatto capire che tutti
noi possiamo trovarci anche
temporaneamente in una condizione in cui
le nostre abilità vengono meno
e pensiamo alla nostra quotidianità
Magari stiamo cucinando abbiamo le mani
impegnate ma vogliamo anche mettere un
timer
Oppure stiamo tenendo in braccio nostra
figlia ma allo stesso tempo vogliamo
sapere che tempo farà domani
Diciamo che mentre stavo preparando
questo intervento mi sono imbattuta nel
Tic Toc di una ragazza che parlava di
disabilità
e ha detto una cosa che mi ha colpito
tantissimo e che mi ha fatto ripensare
alla mia breve esperienza di cecità ha
detto questo è la struttura della
società che dividere persone tra abili e
disabili che crea delle barriere e non
le capacità intrinseche delle persone
io Credo profondamente che il progresso
tecnologico debba abbattere queste
barriere Adesso vediamo proprio come
l'Enel P ci può aiutare a farlo
se torniamo allo schema di prima Vediamo
che tutto quanto funziona perfettamente
fintanto che l'input dell'utente viene
espresso in un parlato standard e in una
lingua standard ma immaginiamo che a
voler utilizzare un assistente vocale
sia invece una persona che non è in
grado di esprimersi in questo modo
pensiamo a chi Magari ha subito un
incidente ma ancora una volta i bambini
che non hanno ancora un controllo totale
del parlato o gli anziani che magari
cominciano ad avere problemi di
articolazione dei suoni Ebbene il P in
questo caso può aiutarci come
Beh sviluppando algoritmi di
intelligenza artificiale e con una
quantità di dati sufficiente siamo in
grado soprattutto per quanto riguarda
srnu di comprendere anche questi input
non standard e di migliorare la
comprensione di questi input nel tempo
ma pensiamo anche a persone affette da
assorbita permanente la nel PIL può
aiutare perché ora possiamo accedere
alla trascrizione automatica dei
sottotitoli quindi la trascrizione
automatica del parlato
ad esempio possiamo avere dei
sottotitoli automatici durante le
videochiamate o vedere proprio
trascritta la risposta dell'assistente
vocale
ma Ricordiamoci che una stordita può
essere anche temporanea a causa di
un'infezione o di un incidente o per
l'invecchiamento ad esempio
pensate all'autonomia che questi
strumenti possono dare alle persone in
diverse fasi della loro vita
Finora abbiamo dato uno sguardo al
passato e al presente di questa
tecnologia Ma come sarà il futuro
futuro sarà probabilmente molto
conversazionale In effetti già Oggi
esistono assistenti vocali specifici
esistono già sul mercato per tenere
compagnia agli anziani Quindi non
soltanto eseguono le normali
funzionalità di un assistente vocale
generico Ma sono anche in grado di
dialogare con le persone per farle
sentire meno sole
e quindi stiamo andando veramente verso
quel futuro immaginato in Star Trek dove
il dialogo uomo macchina è veramente
spontaneo e naturale
e io sono profondamente convinta del
fatto che un giorno ci arriveremo
ma oggi anche voi potete contribuire a
migliorare il futuro di questa
tecnologia
come prima di tutto utilizzatela se
credete che vi sia utile ciò che direte
Infatti ci permetterà di rendere i
nostri sistemi sempre più intelligenti
poi Donate la vostra voce esistono
diversi progetti anche per l'italiano in
cui gli utenti possono registrare la
propria voce e questa verrà utilizzata
per migliorare il riconoscimento
automatico di tutti i tipi di parlato
quindi anche disfonie o accenti diversi
Ma esiste anche poi la possibilità di
donare la voce a chi non ce l'ha quindi
a persone mute dalla nascita in questo
caso
verranno create delle voci sintetiche
sulla base delle voci prestate da voi
credono in rete
il messaggio che vorrei che oggi
portaste a casa con voi è che tutti noi
viviamo delle difficoltà contestuali
e per questo le nostre esigenze rispetto
alla accessibilità possono variare nel
tempo
ed è per questo motivo che è
importantissimo lavorare
sull'accessibilità degli assistenti
vocali attraverso la nel P perché questo
ci permette di immaginare e costruire un
futuro più inclusivo e più accessibile
per tutti e per tutte
Grazie
[Applauso]